hey everybody it's susie shuster in the
rich eisen home studio i've got the rich
eisen mug as i take over just getting
started for rich i am so thrilled to be
here with you today and that's because
i'm going to welcome in in a moment one
of my favorite people on the planet and
that's not hyperbole you know when
there's people in your life that you're
just happy every time you see them that
you walk away every single time thinking
i'm better because i spend time with
them
people who are sweet and nice and caring
and just dirty as sin
that's jeffrey ross the comedian the
roast master general he is going to be
my first guest on just getting started
in just a minute
[Applause]
couldn't be happier on just getting
started to have my great friend jeff
ross as my first guest because i thought
to myself okay who could i have that
i'll feel comfortable with that will
make me laugh
that will make you laugh
i thought it's got to be jeff ross and
so thanks for taking the time to be with
me i mean your schedule's crazy
you do you were just in paris by the way
with dave chappelle
how does one end up going to paris
no
i mean that's not normal impromptu to
use the french word for impromptu
i was at bob saget's funeral
and dave was there and we were emotional
and he had to leave and i didn't
he didn't want to leave and
we weren't done uh morning yet obviously
and he said
hey i'm gonna go to paris tomorrow it's
fashion week i'm gonna do some pop-up
shows um do you want to come
and we could just leave tomorrow and i
said you know what i need one day
to hug my dog to
regroup i and i'll meet you there in two
days
and that's what i did
we did uh five shows in paris i i
thought what a chance to be an american
comic roasting parisians
and i think cobin kind of
zapped the snobbiness out of paris
everybody was very down to earth and
we had a lot of friends there uh to live
and most deaf were there doing black
star and kanye was there and the olsen
twins were there
my pal simon rex had his movie opening
there
and we were surrounded by friends and we
talked about bob on stage in paris
which was kind of fun
and the whole thing was a nice
well much needed change of scenery and
um
you know
you know we all mourn in our own ways so
why not do it over some fresh croissants
and angeline
what was the place you recommended
angelina oh my god that food was good
their hot chocolate is epic i mean you
said two names that go together the
olsen twins and kanye west because when
i think of paris and friends i think of
kanye west and the olsen twins
that did happen we were in the back of
the van me and mary kate and ashley
they're old friends and
and dave did pump up um that song
mary kate actually you know the um the
paris song and it was so classic uh
it was a great time but everything was
on sale uh bought a bunch of clothes
plus you gets all tax free at the
airport you hand them your receipts and
they credit you back like 12 on
everything you buy
so v-a-t v-a-t baby you know so they say
the french are anti-semitic they really
cater to the jewish
uh deal maker in me i
i really enjoyed shopping there and uh
i hadn't been there since i was 18
you know in a youth hostel backpacking
after my dad died which is
come to think of it i just realized i
guess i go to paris after
big losses
you know i want to talk about bob
because
the reason why i had you on in all
honesty was that we spent so much time
together when bob died and we talked and
i reached out to you to make sure you
were okay
uh we both felt a tremendous loss you
more than we because you were so close
to him rich and i loved him and we were
friends with them for 20 years but you
were friends with them even longer
what's your first memory of bob saget
my first memory um
i never watched him as a kid i didn't
watch him full house none of that
ended up for me it wasn't until later
that i realized the impact he had around
the world i knew him as a nightclub
i knew him as a legend that you'd see
his picture around the comedy store
so around when the aristocrats
documentary came out him and i really
became closer because
we we found ourselves side by side doing
press together
talking about free speech in the first
amendment
there were various events on both coasts
and the movie got really hot really
quick and
and i remember
our friendship sealed one day at a
screening a very lady toity screening
in new york that
uh my friend
robin bronk who runs the creative
coalition a nonpartisan arts
group um
she held for the aristocrats and it's a
crowded theater all the you know fancy
new yorkers are there writing about it
reviewing it and they had some of the
cast there
and bob is
probably the biggest star there and he's
sitting next to me and
robin is making a very passionate speech
to everyone about the importance of the
first amendment in free speech and
the the very foundation that america
is built on and right in the middle of
her speech
and don't forget this is a very
irreverent movie and but she really took
it to a very classy place
and right in the middle of her speech
bob whispers in my ear
yell out show us your tits
[Laughter]
he's bob saget i wanted him to be my
friend and he so i just did what he said
i'll show us your tits
and robin
fell on the floor laughing the room
broke up all the tension was released
and
we started to really understand not just
bob but what the movie meant which is
taking things that are sacred and
flipping them upside down and inside out
and making
comedy of it and nothing is too
uh
fragile to make fun of and since then
robin became our very good friend
and uh and i started to really love bob
because he trusted me with that moment i
trusted him
and uh ever since then we would do all
sorts of adventures together we would
travel together we would eat together we
had many fun meals with you susie um
and uh
there was no one more fun at a dinner
table than bob he used non-stop jokes
and
always knew what to order and what
restaurant
you know he'd call me up at
you know 5 30 in the afternoon and say
meat emergency i need some beef ribs
meet me at the brentwood in 45 minutes
i'm like bob i'm in hollywood you got to
give me he's like no no you can make it
i mapped it out let's go i got a
reservation they got one rack left let's
go
it was almost like i put a siren on the
top of my car and we had a
meat emergency
actually of course it means what's more
emergency driven than meat
in the meat business and my dad was a
kosher caterer so we would bond over
meat stories
i remember one night going to craigs
with you guys and when we went home i
said to rich i feel like i had a workout
because it was literally like an
intellectual workout going to dinner
with bob because the jokes would fly
so fast and so furious and he's
again so irreverent that sometimes you'd
feel almost exhausted after a dinner
when it was just me and him
you know he had this patriarchal quality
about him he was a dad on tv he was
america's dad he had three daughters
uh of his own
and
when it was just me and him i always had
this thing with him i'd buy him dinner
and i'd get the check
and he loved that because no one ever
really bought him dinner he was always
expected to buy because he was the
rich guy but you know we all have
expenses and he had a lot of overhead
and a lot of uh
a lot of people to take care of so
[Music]
my sister robin
is a special ed teacher on bainbridge
island up in washington state
and she called me uh
right after bob passed and she said of
all the people you've ever introduced me
to which is many bob was the nicest
well he was the kindest and i think that
one thing that people didn't realize
about him because they either heard
my dog licks my balls they heard
something so ridiculous or they saw him
as danny tanner
what i think was so crazy about him is
very few people really knew him
and those of us that were lucky enough
to be in the inner sanctum
knew a person who was
extraordinarily kind was an incredible
dad you know he and i bonded over his
daughter's migraines that's how we
became such good friends i met him
through jonathan silverman the actor
and i had mentioned that i had a
migraine he told me all about his
daughter and
that's how he bonded and he never forgot
it he always reminded me 20 years later
you know you helped me with my daughter
all that time ago
and
one thing that i've taken from bob's
passing almost more than anything is the
need to tell people that you love them
at the end of a conversation i thought i
think it was that you or was it john
stamos at the memorial who said
everybody get out your your phones
and look and see your last text from bob
and what does it say at the end it said
i love you
and you know
these days don't you need to hear that
even more than ever
we do
and especially during a pandemic you
know bob's podcast was called i'm here
for you and he really was um that was
john who said that at the memorial and
to be honest susie i haven't been able
to look at my text from bob
because i'm just not there yet i haven't
been able to watch any video i landed
back from paris and you know this is
everywhere
it's like
it's not real to me it's still like a
cartoony version like he's playing that
um and i talked to dave coulier today i
talked to stamos last night
um
none of us have really let him go yet
you know you're supposed to mourn and
move on i've experienced a lot of loss
something that i bonded with
bob on over early on
you know we both
were
he lost his sisters i lost my parents
young age
and we would talk to these things were
built as human beings to mourn and then
move on and i haven't quite got to the
moving on phase of this yet i hadn't
lost them
i'd lost really good friends but no one
that i relied on
quite like bob
he needed a recommendation a doctor a
lawyer a
real estate he he understood the
business um
um breakups you know he would he showed
up at my house once two in the morning
took me to astro burger for a pastrami
sandwich
you know after a bad breakup and i'm
crying over my pastrami sandwich it is
lexus
you know bob gave me a pep talk that
lasted longer than the whole
relationship i was crying about
you know he really was a good
solid
friend and
let's face it he had every chance to be
some hollywood phony and he never did it
he had every chance to be some bitter
[ __ ] and he never did it um
you know the life kind of yanked him a
few times with
lost
and he he kept punching and he kept
working working and making people laugh
and bringing joy to people
i guess we're all a little older a
little wiser having known bob
how do you think comedy will help you
more
it immediately was therapeutic for me um
the very next night after his
it's a good question by the way because
i i also asked myself that question
the night after his
funeral which you were at um
john mayer texted me and dave chappelle
and said
you know dave asking dave to play
another day
so that we could um
do a impromptu what i called a punk rock
shiva
in the little tiny 50 seat belly room at
the comedy store and
and that's what we did
and
i said to myself you know i remember
after my old dog nana the old german
shepherd died
a few months ago i remember sitting here
with the puppy going now what do i do
just sit in the house and cry
i thought you know what why don't i just
pack up this puppy and go to one of
these outdoor comedy spots and just talk
about it
and
and when this happened with bob i
thought to myself at first i was like i
don't want to go to the comedy store i
don't want
i i can't face the girls crying i can't
face bob's daughters
um and and kelly his wife crying
but then i thought you know what i've
never gone on stage and regretted it
i've never gone on stage even decades
ago when my grandfather died i waited a
week and then i went on stage and i felt
a little better
it it fortifies you to share it to tell
stories and i went upstairs i went up
last night at the comedy store and i
told some bob jokes and some bob stories
and
that made me feel a lot better pretty
quickly
um
yeah i said you know you might have you
might have heard that uh our friend john
mayer very generously paid for a private
jet
fly bob's home body home from the road
where he died
so what you might not know is that i
paid for the goodyear blimp to fly lily
anderson's body home
so
when you're in the comedy store this
temple of free speech
like it's just a release of the tension
a release
of the sadness and you start to laugh
through your pain and i always say to
myself if i don't laugh i cry so
i try to keep
i try to keep um my sense of humor
intact through these things it also
feels like my role in in
in life is to try to
use my
experience with loss to
help people get through it
i'm curious and this is called just
getting started so this is the perfect
segue
how old were you when you realized
that you had a gift for comedy or that
you were attracted to comedy when was
the first time you had an inclination
this is pretty great
when i
at 48 years old i was like i think i'm i
think i
think i'm gonna stick with this
so last night i thought to myself hey
kid i got a career
you know i didn't see it
it was my pal mark chapin my college
buddy
two years after college i was going
through a rough time
my grandfather and i were living
together like you know sort of on my own
my parents were long gone
and i was with my grandfather who was
very sick and i was taking care of him
and my college buddies said you should
take this comedy class
it's over by port authority it's on your
way home
from your day job and i think you'd be
good at it he gave me a couple examples
of me making him laugh over the years
just being silly and
he's like oh you know maybe you'll meet
a chick there maybe you'll get a little
social life out of it
i think you'd be good at it so i didn't
understand any of that
i didn't want to be a comic i didn't
understand that that was even something
you could do i thought comics were old
guys and tuxedos from the catskills or
on johnny carson shows so
it took someone else motivating me
to get started
and
i'm very grateful to my friend mark
we're still very very very close pals
and talk all the time
but
once i started doing it
i remember doing that you know getting a
few of those laughs and at that point in
the beginning you're like trying to
piece together an act and
somebody came up to me after some
crappy little gig in new jersey you know
decades ago
she says my husband is you know
we had so much fun he has cancer i
haven't heard him laugh like that in so
long
wow so this is bigger than me this is
bigger than
what i'm getting paid what they're gonna
what i can order from the kitchen what
my name looks like in the
on the marquee this is so much bigger
than all that
and i realized that there was a healing
quality
to even
body humor
and it was a long time in there i mean
if this is about getting started then
i'll tell you it was a long time in
there where
i told people yeah i'm doing stand-up
comedy and they'd say stuff like well
you'll figure out life you'll figure
something out it was like i got
dismissed as a quack like that you know
no nice jewish boy with a college
education was going to be a comic it
didn't make sense
uh in the you know
early 90s 1989
so part of it is
somebody else pushing you and then part
of it is
you see you yourself as an entertainer
as an artist
seeing the
good
that it can bring people and since then
forget it it's like
dave chappelle says you want to go to
paris what american comics you could
probably count them on one hand who've
done stand up in paris
so to me it's been a backstage pass to
the world i get to see
things i never get to see
uh i got to meet rich eisen on a street
corner after 9 11. i got to uh go to
super bowls and and i got to go to uh
embassies all over the world
on uso tours to war zones
meet the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff i've met the last few presidents
um
it's been a really
great ride
what do you tell what do you tell jeff
what do you tell the kid
who was leaving his day job what was
your day job back then by the way
i was after college a buddy a college
buddy and i went to film school we
started a
a production company we made training
films
for like health and beauty aids
companies and
very
dry stuff like that
so what do you tell that kid
who
had the balls
to start something new
if you had to tell that kid
in 25 years you're going to be in paris
with dave chappelle
what would that kid have said
besides who the [ __ ] dave chappelle
because this is 25 years ago but besides
the high school kid
um
for me
i said to myself at the time
because i recognized
that i would liked it a lot and i reckon
and i'd experienced enough loss with my
parents and
grandfather and so on dying
my aunt best like i'd experienced enough
loss already by the time i was starting
comedy 23 years of age
i realized that um
it could hurt me if i loved it too much
it could hurt me the rejection the
the
just the grind
and
there's a lot of creeps in comedy it was
a rough business
so i said to myself i put up a
uh for sure a force shield
to protect myself and i said to myself
if i do it once
on tv
i'll be okay with never doing it again
i promised myself i wouldn't let it
become
everything to me
and
i've a couple of times in the last 32
years my anniversary is coming up
uh april fool's day will be 33 years
as a comic um
i i i promised myself that i that that
that i would be in control of it and it
wouldn't control me and that i would
love it
and use it and
and and
have it bring me joy you know i always
thought of comedy as a hobby not a job i
thought it was a job i probably would be
selling at arenas but
but i always thought of it as a hobby i
never wanted it to be to own me
and you know when the pandemic hit and
um you know you don't get to do it for a
year
it didn't crush me because i remembered
what i told myself
as a 23 year old open micro like
um
that
that if i only did it that one time i'd
be okay and if it gets taken away from
me i'll survive
so
part of it is that and another part of
it is
and i have a big neon
um
sign in my house in my living room over
the fireplace that says enjoy the
process
and i have to remind myself that all the
time and when young comics ask me about
it i always
tell them you know
you can't just work towards
the goals the money the accolades
you have to enjoy
the ups and downs you know
when you're when your internet goes out
right before a live zoom show or you get
rejected or your car breaks down right
before a gig or you bomb
in front of your
ex-girlfriend or your ex-agent
you know you have to have an
appreciation
for how hard it is and kind of love that
you know what doesn't kill you makes you
funnier and the life experience that
goes into it
you get thick skin and
it makes you sort of invincible
and
i always think of like
there's no end game with comedy like or
even show business like
you know
tom cruise has got everything in the
world but some days he's probably
sitting there going [ __ ] george
clooney god damn it you know there's
always somebody doing a little better on
any given week
so i go enjoy the process never too high
never too low sometimes my manager will
go you got the job why aren't you
jumping up and down i go
i'll jump up and down when it airs and
then a month later somebody walks up to
me at the mall and goes you were good on
that show then i'll be happy but until
then there's too many things that could
go belly up
so i really do try to control my
emotions and look at it as a process and
not necessarily
goal oriented all the time
what was your first tv gig do you
remember exactly
oh man star search 1992. no way with ed
was it was that uh out there
this week's challenger
lip shits
and that's when you realize i'm going to
change my name uh-huh on the flight home
because i won a couple episodes and i
kept advancing and every time i advanced
that mcmahon would [ __ ] up my name even
more and when you're jeffrey lip schultz
they had to use a different font to get
my name on the screen and i was so
embarrassed that my name was so long and
everybody else had this big flashy name
on their screen and this is the first
time my family's seeing me do anything
so
um star search was big i flew down to
florida
i knew i was gonna win the contest i
brought two duffel bags worth of clothes
i was there for four days but i thought
i was going to be there for two months
to win the whole thing
and um my buddy keith robinson dragged
the
help me drag the duffel bags into my
hotel room because i couldn't afford a
bellhop or anything like that and
and he was leaving he got eliminated and
was and i was coming
and
i was so desperate to rehearse i would
go on the little boats to take you from
epcot to the hotels and i'd grab the mic
and and or i'd give the the disney
worker five bucks to let me conduct a
tour just so i could practice my two and
a half minute routine before the live
taping just practice saying it so yeah
it was star search it was ed mcmahon and
i credit with ed with convincing me to
go to jeff ross my middle name
um
as my stage name
were you scared
performing on stage when you first
started out
no
i felt free i was scared
to not perform i was scared to miss out
every time there's a saturday night
comes around when i don't have a show i
feel like i've wasted a week of my life
even if i'm out even if i'm at a wedding
or a party here
or whatever it is like i i
i uh
i feel free the most free when i'm on
stage you know everybody talks about
political correctness and cancer culture
and
woke comedy but
that all exists on the internet and in
real life and in corporate you know
meetings but when you're i'm on stage
i'm like a gunslinger i don't give a
flying [ __ ] about any of that and i'm
just trying to make people laugh
and express myself in a way
that is pure
and
i just did
four sold out shows in salt lake city
this past weekend everybody said oh
those mormons blah blah blah they're
very conservative there won't be anybody
of color in the audience i get to my
show and
it is
mixed it's a very gay friendly city so
you get a very diverse
uh audience and man almost just hitting
on all cylinders they didn't they're you
know you can't really pre-judge
audiences anymore all that
stuff we hear about
cancel culture and wokeness i know that
exists everywhere but inside those
comedy rooms those temples of free
speech are true safe spaces to let it
rip it's healthy not like it's hate
speech i'm up there making people laugh
laugh at themselves i'm making fun of
myself the most
um
the other day i said i i look like if
amazon sold to jeff bezos blow up oh i
heard that one uh-huh
and
what's so funny is that you use
self-deprecation
in the kindest and gentlest of ways
because if you can't be self-deprecating
in takers if you can't take yourself
with a grain of salt
you live your whole life with a chip on
your shoulder
exactly and there's nothing worse than a
bitter person especially a bitter comic
like that is such a turn-off i'm trying
to remember who it was i was watching
the alec baldwin roast this morning and
by the way the greatest way to prep for
something
when i used to prep for football games
and i'm looking at a hundred names times
two downs and distance boring stuff and
what did i do to prep for this i watched
the alec baldwin roast i mean the
greatest prep of all time
who was it that called you
the leftover caitlyn jenner's penis
and then you stood up straight out
and of course i love you so i was like
oh jeff no but you know
i don't remember i said that but i gotta
i owe that person to thank you that's
pretty good it was hysterical when did
you when did you realize
that you could incorporate roasting into
comedy
it was again another happy accident
susie it wasn't me
it was a year where
the friars club um was struggling to get
celebrities on on these shows they
weren't televised yet they were just
this sort of
inside show business thing in new york
and they couldn't get people
um they had controversies and so on and
it was like the roasting it was kind of
antiquated it was like a lost art like
jousting or something no one really knew
what it was outside the walls of the
friars club in new york milton berlin
had a young man and buddy hacking and
these guys
so
when i realized
i could always do a little bit of crowd
work i could make fun of people as they
went to the bathroom at the comedy clubs
and i was getting good at them seeing i
learned how to do that by m sing i
always want to host shows so that i get
to go on in between the comics and talk
to the audience like i thought that
would be good training if i ever hosted
a game show or a talk show whatever
and i think i built some roasting skills
so that when i did some private show at
a for the friars club in a golf
tournament boom i already had some skill
on how to do that
and when the old guys would make fun of
me i could come back at them and nobody
they were so revered nobody ever did
that so when i started doing that they
were like here's a guy who knows where
the line is he respects us but he
doesn't revere us in a way that keeps
him from ripping into us
and
i got better and better at the roasts
and people i got started to get a
reputation as a roaster so i was like
you know what why don't i just start
mixing that into my stand up
so now when i do a show and i'm touring
now
i'll do half an hour of whatever i want
stand up stories of the world talk about
whatever i want and
and then a certain point i dive into
let's turn the lights on and see who's
here no one's to come up and get roasted
and volunteers only and people
inevitably start pointing to each other
and i said no no no that's bullying you
have to raise your own hand and then
people come up and i line them up like a
police line up and just go boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom for 15 minutes
roast a dozen people um
and it's like a party on stage and
it's a perfect combination of roasting
and stand up i'll talk about my dog
dying
uh for 10 minutes and then
send right into a live speed roast so it
i like to play with emotions i like to
take people on a little bit of a ride on
stage you know you have an hour you can
do all sorts of different colors with
that
you know it's funny one of my favorite
things of your instagram besides your
dogs and when you're doing yoga on your
back deck usually wearing something very
skimpy
is
how many people send in pictures from
all over the world of themselves doing
the dumbest things and they say
jeff roast me why do you think people
like to be roasted so much
that's a great question that question i
get so much
and
i don't like it so i have to try to
figure out
why people do like it like i'd be a
hypocrite if i got sensitive obviously
these jokes like you said somebody made
a joke about me looking like a penis i'm
like okay
i deserve it i dish it out i better be
able to take it and then at the end of
my show i do roast myself sometimes so i
get why it's important to show both
sides but why do celebrities or even my
fans want to come on stage and get
roasted honestly i have no [ __ ] idea
i wouldn't want to do it in a million
years
my only thing i can think about is
the ones that have really
loved it the most are the biggest
egomaniacs
alex paul donald trump bieber like so i
think everyone loves to be the center of
attention
even if there's a target on their back
it's still an hour and a half all about
them
and
it's a good way to show
your fans your family your friends
that you uh
are a person of the people
a man of the people
and you can take a joke
and
we live in america where no one is
royalty no one you can you can talk
smack on anybody
so it's a phenomenon that
must go back to the early days of man
why why do people make fun of each other
is it a way to bond is it a way to
release tension is it a way to
build people up you know
um
i think when you were talking about
mourning
and about comedy and it goes back to
that
rich and i met you right after 9 11
and you were not jeffrey ross
rose master general yet i mean you were
building something you were
you were doing the roast in manhattan
with rickles and all the giants of
comedy who really was like a dad for you
but
it was before the roasts got so big we
went into right after 9 11. i don't i
think rich was there because i was still
out in la
and you invited him to do
the 9 11 roast
and of course the famous thing that came
out of it was too soon right too soon
and
and we go back again and you should
probably explain the two soon drugs
maybe you could take us there
and explain what made that roast just so
special
well
new york was on its heels
new york had been attacked and nobody
ever saw that coming obviously it was a
sneak attack from terrorists and
you know it all reads in the history
books now but when you're actually a
mile north of the twin towers and you
have a you're a comic
i couldn't help but wonder
is it over this comedy kind of dead
irony sarcasm
dave chappelle and his wife and kid
evacuated the soho grand
came to my house covered in ash
i found them outside they ran up a mile
you know
he was a you know also obviously now
we're two comedians and
and i called my manager when the phone
started working again
bernie brolstein who'd been around for
decades
and i said ernie he needs
you know what what does this mean for
our business and he was stammering he
just said i don't know kid i don't know
and when the old guys don't know what's
happened
now you know you're in unchartered
territory
now you go this is our moment
now we're going to tell every you know
i'm
the young guy in my early 30s at that
point
and i go wow this is
time to step up
and
you're not going to get guidance from
the seniors this time
so i thought about it overnight
and you know we tried to donate blood
and everything but there was nobody
needed any blood there was not those
sorts of injuries it was
who would
die to the world trade center died
immediately
and so now you're just faced with what
can i do what can i do
this is happening all around me i'm
walking around outside like this because
you know with my with my shirt over my
nose because
there's human ash
uh floating through new york
and it felt hopeless
but that didn't sit well with me i'd
already lost my parents i already
understood what hopelessness
felt like
and i wrote a letter
to hugh hefner
the friars club and comedy central this
is the early days of email
and i'd already been getting calls from
the production saying
you know we have a roast scheduled um
a couple weeks from now but the hilton
needs to know for going you know
they want to keep the deposit and we're
not going through with the show we're
going to lose all this money and i was a
junior producer on the show i was a
low-level producer but i was a big part
of the team that
you know got them together but i didn't
have a lot of experience back then
and
something just didn't sit well with me
with kids
hugh hefner who you know
is the very reason terrorists hate us
right sexual
freedom
first amendment stuff
you know
he published naked pictures and dirty
jokes and he lived this sort of
sexual lifestyle and
it seemed like
this is the very definition of the
terrorist winning
before that was a cliche expression
if we canceled a terrorist win
it really felt that way
it's like they're going to take
everything away from us
including our ability to laugh
and celebrate
what a great country we live in the
first amendment free speech
and not only that but
i had sarah silverman and jimmy kimmel
and adam corolla and
steve carell and stephen colbert and
rich and so many of my friends were all
planning on being a part of this and
i wrote this letter basically explaining
that
i thought the sh the roast must go on
you know the old show business the show
must go on and i said let's just cancel
the after party
make it a fundraiser for the twin towers
and
we'll
we'll get we'll put whatever money we
have towards getting f
and his
girlfriends
and
the roasters coming in center of the
entertainer and and
and
dick gregory and all these
great people had to travel in for it and
that was brave at that point just
getting on a plane
and
i convinced everybody to go on with the
show
um somewhere i still have that letter
i'm very proud of it um
and it worked it like released this
amazing amount of tension and sadness
from new york
you know these roasts aren't just on tv
there's 2 000 new yorkers
packed into the ballroom with the new
york hilton
and you really felt it when jimmy kimmel
went up there as the host
started doing some light humor and
breaking the ice
and slowly by the end of the set
everybody's kind of laughing and
laughing and by the time the next comic
comes up and the next i remember rob
schneider came up second or third and he
was doing fine we got a joke kind of
missed and then another joke missed and
he's like you know
and i ran up and i put mama i put my arm
around him and i said hasn't there been
enough bombing in this city
and when i went right to it like that
it was like a
huge it felt at least for me a huge
relief like i gotten a laugh about the
tragedy and that kind of i felt like
opened it up it got bad more and more
and then jimmy started going in on hef
and his girlfriend's a little harder and
you know he had seven girlfriends at the
time i said why does f have seven
girlfriends one to put it in the other
six to move them around
and and and by the time gilbert
gottfried went out at the end
all the clever silly whatever jokes have
been told so the girl was like [ __ ]
i'm just gonna tell a long crazy dirty
joke that
the terrorists would really hate
a super sexual crazy joke about
the aristocrats this crazy family of
show business people a family of mother
father and two kids and a dog that all
basically [ __ ] each other on stage it's
the most absurd crazy thing you've ever
heard
um
and yogurt goes into it
but as he's going into it he does this
joke
where he says
i almost didn't make it here i my plane
had a connection at the empire state
building
and somebody else too soon it was a
genuine moment from an audience member
not set up
it was too soon
and
gilbert's taken aback by that and
usually he's encouraged to go harder
uh but we're all laughing and that's
when he grabbed the podium like it was
about to blast off in his space and he
squinted around and then he just went
into this long crazy dirty aristocrats
joke
and it brought the house down you can
see footage of it in the aristocrats
movie that came out years later where me
and jimmy were all laughing rolling on
the floor drew carey was there and um
we're laughing so hard and it's funny
because that's the movie that
brought bob and i together years later
as friends
but comedy is healing that i think is a
really important thing
to talk about and to appreciate it
people forget that
and
for what it's worth the crowds
right now wherever i
go are the best crowds i've ever
performed for whether they're in paris
or salt lake or oxnard it's like people
missed comedy all year
and i think not having it has made them
appreciate what it does for them
psychologically i mean think about it
susie like two years old pandemic the
death rate
the divorce rate the suicide rate ask
any shrink it's business is booming
so comedy
makes a lot of sense
that people would want it more and the
audience would be more appreciative than
they've ever been you don't get
obnoxious heckling you don't get random
[ __ ] with their cell phones trying
to get a moment out of contact all that
seems to be gone
and people are really zoned in on
the healing powers of life you find your
rooms have any partisan break depending
on what jokes you're telling
my politically no
mine don't because i play
i play it
pretty even keel if i make a joke about
donald trump
rest assured it's a joke that donald
trump's
supporters would also probably laugh at
even if it's a criticism and it almost
exists
uh if i make fun of joe biden which i do
uh it's done in a way that
even joe biden would last so you're an
equal opportunity offender which is very
smart
i think so and if i do have a political
agenda it's implied
it's not overt
because at the end of the day you don't
get anywhere
with a hammer
with me it's it's about the the you know
sliding it into somebody's brain without
them realizing
and then as they repeat the joke to
their friends back home they start to go
oh there's something behind that
something that informs my political
opinions and they start to get it
um
i think that's the key to changing
people to being persuasive is
not telling them how it should be but
letting them figure it out on their own
because they laughed at something that
they can't believe they laughed
the hypocrisy like part of being a
comedian is like sifting through the
[ __ ] what's your favorite joke
whichever one's next babe
my favorite joke is always the newest
joke
so what are you working on what are you
working on give us a little preview
at least let me look at my phone for a
second i wrote something down yesterday
let's see what's on here
here's a little preview this is a this
is what this would be what would we call
this a um
special just getting started preview
this would be a uh
um
what's the word
is this an exclusive right if we if we
if we were on extra i'd be like well
jeffrey ross has gotten an exclusive for
us here on just getting started
sneak peek
and covered um it was awful
and uh
i was sick as a dog but
the weirdest part was
afterwards i lost my sense of taste
it got so bad i went to see dave
matthews
but that's clean for you
yeah well you know
but it still bites and dave
matthews uh i think he would laugh you
know the other thing that i think is
interesting that i'd like to share with
those of you who are listening to just
getting started
humor is filthy
it's filthy i mean there are there are
moments that are just embarrassing i
mean there's so much fun because you
laugh because you're uncomfortable right
and you laugh because you can't believe
you went there
but you laughed because
did he you seen yourself did he just say
that out loud
and it's funny jeff because
it's the opposite of who you are in real
life
you are kind and caring and thoughtful
and
generous
and sweet
how do you rationalize
the two sides of jeff ross
thank you for that
um
i don't
i just would
i don't think at least i'm told
by experts
i wouldn't get away with
busting balls if i was burning bridges
if i didn't roast people that i love
i wouldn't be getting away with it if i
found people i didn't like
and roasted them i'd be a different type
of entertainer i don't think that would
have legs
i think you you run out of gas like that
the secret of it all is if i'm gonna
roast
and i go through the whole boom boom get
everybody rickle style and i leave you
out
that's the insult
that's the person i don't like
if i leave you out of it
you are like
not important to me or
i don't think you can take it or i don't
think you're worth mentioning
you know
so to me
i
i find the truth in comedy i understand
that people laugh at honestly brutal
honesty sometimes but it's also like
of course i'm kidding if i call somebody
i did a joke
in salt lake the other night where a
beautiful couple beautiful mary bubble
on stage and i made a joke
um that the woman was not attract
and
her knees buckled with laughter and the
whole audience laughed and the reason
they laughed is because they know that i
know that she knows she's beautiful
and
it's a joke
and
it's like
there's no
malice behind it it's meant to be light
it's meant to give them a chance to
flirt with each other on stage as a
married couple a little spark to the
night
you know there's nothing worse susie
when you go to a comedy show
and the comic starts talking about
the differences between men and women
or
or sexual uh diseases or divorce
like bitterness
like i i come from the buddy hacking
school of i want to be the best wingman
you know
let's just say it's your anniversary and
you ask your husband to go to a comedy
show i want to be the guy that
lights you two up
so that you when you see me a year later
you go oh my god that night we saw you
we laughed so hard we banged all night
and now i'm pregnant and here's our new
baby you know it's like that's
to me the fun thing like not like
oh man you know you really you really
spoke the truth about men and women and
[ __ ] all that like i want it to be a
party i want to be the best wingman i
want my show to be sexy and fun and
bring people together i want everyone to
leave going that was fun i gotta do that
again i want whoever listens to this to
walk away feeling like
they have laughed
they've been inspired
and
they got some direction because i think
everybody needs a little bit of help
these days everybody needs a push
everybody needs some guidance
and everybody needs somebody to extend a
hand to them to say you're gonna be okay
so
what would you leave this audience with
jeff
from your experience getting started
what's your advice
years and years ago
dave chappelle and i were at a comedy
festival in las vegas he would remember
this too
and it was four in the morning we were
both done shows
the parties were over we were hungry
and we found a quiet spot in one of the
diners in the casino
we're just shooting the [ __ ]
and i see some kid who starts walking
over
and he wants to talk to us
and dave you know he gave him a little
wave over and you think
any advice same question you know i'm
just starting out any advice
and
dave said it right away he said just
keep in mind
you only start out once
and it made a lot of sense to the guy
and i understood where dave was coming
from it's like
this is the hard part and starting out
getting started is the hard part
it's also the best part in a lot of ways
because the future is
wide open
and
it might feel like starting out takes a
long time but that's okay too because
you're earning it you're building up
credit you're building up life
experience you're
building up relationships you're
building up everything you need to
go the distance but you only start out
once you can interpret it a million ways
but
i think that really stuck with me it's
like
it gets better i'm gonna borrow a page
from our friend bob i'm gonna tell you i
love you and i'm so grateful that you
did this thank you for breaking the ice
with me
you were the best way for me to like
get back into the chair get to practice
asking questions again i'm not talking
to myself it's kind of great but i loved
having you on as my first guest and i'm
so grateful
my pleasure i love you too
good luck with the podcast i think it'll
be really fun for people to hear these
stories from different guests about
getting started and all that
you know i could talk about bob all day
i could talk about you all day so you're
a muffin i'm gonna call up all your
friends and say hey come on and talk
about bob i think it's a great way for
us to to kind of
feel warm and fuzzy about him again and
to share as you said you can share your
pain but you can also share a laugh
yeah
why not i mean life's short you know and
you forget that something sometimes
people just
they're just gone in a second so you
might as well uh laugh about it
because the alternative is
crying
you smear the mascara it's not a good
look
it's not a good look and
you don't want to see me cry in public
it's bad i look like a
doctor
love you jeff
do you own a renter home sure you do and
i bet it can be hard work you know
what's easy bundling policies with geico
geico makes it easy to bundle your
homeowners or renters insurance along
with your auto policy it's a good thing
too because you already have so much to
do around your home go to geico.com get
a quote see how much you could save it's
geico easy visit geico.com today that's
geico.com
[Applause]
our thanks to jeff ross who's busy
tucking away what is that a turkey
sandwich
turkey and uh cheese and bacon and some
other [ __ ]
next time i will supply you with some
something delicious to drink i think i
would prefer to do just getting started
with something
liquid and not just like a cup of coffee
any crappy rich eisen mug but
next time i'll have you i will have a
little bit of wine or something to go
with that but
i want to thank you jeff for being my
first guest ever
on just getting started there'll be a
lot more just getting started dropping
very soon michael urban coming up
marshall falk
uh i've got paul rudd coming up i want
to have a really eclectic bunch of
people on just getting started because
everyone's got a great origin story
right jeff
oh yeah i love that and come out for a
laugh you and richard come out to the
comedy store one night or come see me i
would love that we're gonna post
alongside of that all of your upcoming
tour dates and in fact i can go into
here really quickly i'm gonna read some
out loud
we're looking at
we're going to get you out for break
california march 4th and 5th april 7th
8th and 9th in denver
may 13th and 14th in irvine may 27th
28th and 29th in portland oregon
because there's a lot of funny people up
there uh june 9th 10th and 11th in
indianapolis the 16th 17th and 18th of
june in austin texas and the 15th and
the 16th
in oxnard california
so find jeff ross also check out his
instagram because jeffrey your instagram
is pretty good again i want to bring up
the people who send in their photos
who get roasted
and the photos are insane by the way
like the the people
i find the ripest ones well i love them
but that is one of my favorite parts but
once again i want to thank jeff and say
thank you to all of you who took the
time to stop by and listen to this just
getting started i hope that made you
happy
yep thanks sis i hope that you enjoyed
this edition of just getting started
many more where that came from looking
forward to touching base with you and
hearing back from you as well about
people that you'd want to hear from
about their origin stories and how they
just got started take care everybody see
you soon